welcome to the show everybody thanks for
watching as you could see a different
set today I'm not happy about it I'm not
in my car I'm in a hotel room in
Cincinnati I had a speaking gig last
night and so that's why I'm here I don't
like the it's way too open it's way too
big I like to be in the enclosed cocoon
of the car I don't really like that
what's the opposite of claustrophobic is
it a agoraphobic or is that something
else I don't know but whatever it is
that's what I that's how I feel
I just die in the sitting in this vast
50 square foot hotel room it's just very
bewildering but I'll try to get past
that so we can talk because this is an
important topic I want to get into a
couple of things happen last week that
I've been wanting to do a video about
for a few days now first Hawaii became
either the fifth or sixth state to
legalize euthanasia and a few days
before that there was a disturbing story
out of Canada which by the way Canada is
the source of quite a few disturbing
stories as of late Canada is like the
new Florida or something I don't know
what's going on up there in Canada but
you guys need to figure that thing out
in this case it was about an elderly
couple who was married for over 70 years
and they decided to commit suicide
together or as the media puts it they
decided to receive a a doctor assisted
death so that's the new you know we went
from suicide euthanasia to doctor
assisted suicide now we call it
receiving a doctor assisted death so
you're receiving death like you know
it's a gift it's like it's like a gift
that you receive on Christmas morning
except in this case it's poison in your
veins and you're dead so we're receiving
death if you ever wonder why we call our
culture the culture of death that's why
because we we are literally treating it
like a gift that we've given someone
like a birthday present
their names were George and Shirley
brick and N and they decided that they
wanted to commit suicide together so
they they announced it to the family
and they went through a series of they
had a reception they went through a
series of these McCobb kind of farewell
ceremonies much like you may you know if
you maybe walked into a restaurant or
something you saw going on you would
think oh they're having a retirement
party or oh they're you know they're
moving to the moving down south to a new
to a retirement home and everyone's
coming to say goodbye know they were
doing this because they were killing
himself when the time came we're told by
the media reports they laid in bed
together and they held hands and then a
doctor injected poison into their veins
a lethal injection just like they would
do to two criminals to convicted
murderers and their closest loved ones
apparently stood it that stood at the
foot of the bed and watched their
parents die now they are not the first
married couple I hate to say who have
received death in this way a couple in
the Netherlands had what they called
their deepest wish fulfilled when they
committed suicide together a couple in
Oregon had their own wish fulfilled
a few years ago in the same kind of way
a few months ago actually you know it
was originally claimed if you're
wondering why you should care about this
well we're gonna talk about that but
first of all you should care about it
because it's just disgusting inhumane
and horrific but also it was claimed
originally that euthanasia would be
something about would reserve it only
for individual adults who are terminally
ill that's always said that we were told
that's all it is individual adult
terminally ill on their deathbed then
they can get euthanasia but as with
everything else with the left the
analogy I've used before is when you're
when you were a kid maybe you read the
book if you give a mouse a cookie and
that's all about this cookie that you
know the kid gives them a mouse the kid
gives the mouse a cookie then he comes
back and he wants a glass of milk or
they know what's a napkin then he wants
a fork for some
and before you know he's he's eating
them out of house and home because he
just kept the kid just kept say she
ating the mouse so the left is a lot
like that they're like the mouse in that
in that disturbing fable or you give
them one thing except that the cookies
that they want are again horrific but
you give them the one thing you think
that's it and then they come back and
they say oh actually can I have this -
oh you know while we're here how about
that as well so it started with
euthanasia individual adults terminally
ill and now we treat it like a romantic
getaway for for for elderly couples or
you know we also have in Europe and I'm
sure it will be here soon enough
euthanasia for people who are depressed
euthanasia for people who are alcoholics
euthanasia for children that's what's
happening in Europe you see the culture
of death is a cancer and it spreads and
it consumes and it never ever stops it
will never get to a point where it says
oh that's enough we'll leave you alone
never stops it whittles away at life on
both end as ends of the spectrum so we
were working on the the unborn babies
we're killing them off and then we come
in on the other end with the elderly and
the sick and then we Whittle them away
to until we're kind of just you know
we're just sort of meeting in the middle
so that you're not safe unless you're a
27 year old college-educated completely
healthy person that's that's where we're
headed where that's that's the only you
know if you're if you follow to that
demographic then we can use you in
society if not we got to get rid of you
um and that's why because it's all part
of this greater agenda on the left
that's why the left can barely contain
their enthusiasm when it comes to
euthanasia whenever there's a famous
euthanasia case they just fall they trip
over themselves to congratulate the
person remember Brittany Maynard a
couple years ago was a famous one in
Oregon I believe and she announced ahead
of time that she was getting doctor
assisted suicide and the left and the
media they were just ecstatic they were
like oh she's so courageous such a
beautiful thing
you know it's just imagine for a moment
a man I mean I'm in a hotel room right
now it's like 20 stories high so imagine
there was a guy standing up on the roof
20 stories up and he was about to jump
and what the left is doing basically is
they're they're coming up and they're
saying oh wow you're so brave yes
jump die with dignity you're so
courageous this is so wonderful I mean
brings a tear to my eye it's such a
beautiful thing what really is the
difference between cheering a guy on
who's standing on the ledge of a
building and sharing somebody on who's
going to a doctor who did a poison pill
or a poison injection what's the
difference there's no difference
it's suicide either way now we could try
to dress up euthanasia call it something
else you know have them lay down in the
bed we call it medicine we say they're
receiving death but in the end it's the
same thing as jumping off a building in
fact jumping off a building is probably
a more painless death really so there's
no difference that's why I get upset
about I get a percent about it for the
same reason that I would be upset if
there was a guy in the building and then
you came up and said yeah go for it or
if I was trying to talk him off the
ledge and you say hey how dare you mind
your business if the guy wants to jump
let him jump but if you did that we
would all agree that you are a monster
right everyone in society would agree
that if you cheered on someone
committing suicide you're a monster but
if you did it in the context of
euthanasia then well you're just a
liberal so people were you know the left
was gushing over this suicide and the
main thing that you hear over and over
again whether it's with the brick and
Den's or it's with Brittany Maynard or
whoever else it's that well they're
dying with dignity but no they're not
it's exactly the opposite now we're told
that
origins surely that they you know they
lived wonderful full lives and they were
good people I hope that's true I didn't
know them personally but if it is true
it makes it all the worse in the end
that they chose to be put down like dogs
just makes it worse because that life of
dignity they just punted in the end and
their family cheered it on and applauded
and encouraged it where is the dignity
in that let me ask you when your dog
gets very old and he's sick you take him
to the doctor and they strap them down
and they inject something into them
where is the dignity in a human being
being discarded like that dignity is
found when you embrace life and you
persevere through difficulty suicide is
the opposite of that it is the up it is
the diameter there's dignity here and
then there's suicide all the way on the
opposite end it diametrically opposed
they are it's like up and down North and
South dignity and suicide there is no
such thing as a dignified suicide a man
of dignity is a man of self-respect you
can't respect yourself if you're
destroying yourself it's not possible
self annihilation and self-respect
cannot be the same because once you've
annihilated yourself there's no self
left to respect now here's here's what
happens when you question the dignity of
suicide and by the way not just with
euthanasia but I have found when you
question the dignity of any kind of
suicide even if a guy is jumping off a
building or whatever else whenever you
do that people get very upset they they
don't want you to besmirched the dignity
of suicide
and they say that it's cruel and it's
heartless how dare you I've heard this
many times anytime I've talked about the
subject but you know what I say to that
how dare you if you're in the
euthanasia pro suicide can't you're the
one who's heartless and cruel you're the
heartless cruel monster not me
not only are you encouraging more people
to murder themselves by glorifying
suicide but you are very clearly
implying that the people who don't kill
themselves yet yet are terminally ill or
very old you're clearly implying that
they do not have dignity you what what
you're saying is if it's dignified to
kill yourself before death naturally
takes you then it must be undignified to
wait around for it to take you both of
those strategies can't be dignified so
what you're saying is that a cancer
patient who dies who dies in his bed
naturally you're saying he lacks dignity
you're saying that an old man who
decides to live and cherish every moment
that God has given him you're saying
that he lacks dignity if euthanasia is
dignified it is dignified because you
are avoiding a slow and drawn-out death
what about the ones who don't avoid it
what you're saying if you're in this
camp you're saying that they are the
ones who don't have dignity so yeah you
could accuse me of besmirching suicide
I'd rather besmirched suicide than
besmirched life itself it we're so
desperate in this culture to hold up
suicide as this grand and elegant thing
that we turn life into a dirty and
shameful thing these people they hail
the courage of a man who kills himself
to avoid suffering and in the process
they make a coward of a guy who who
embraces his suffering and finds a
meaning in it so that's the
that's the dignity part of this there is
no dignity dignity again is in someone
who is given life and embraces it no
matter how much suffering is involved
that's what it means to die with dignity
even if you're in a hospital bed even if
you even if you're even if you're
whittling away from a from an illness or
something there's still a lot of dignity
in that and the people that accept that
fate and who die with courage and you
know on God's time the other thing that
people say about euthanasia is that it
allows someone to go out their own way
and to take charge and to exercise
autonomy and so on
we'll say all these they're doing it
their way right so we say about the
brick and Den's they're doing it their
way well there are a few problems with
that first of all euthanasia is not
doing it your way you aren't taking
charge of anything if you can really
take ownership of yourself if you could
really be in charge of yourself that I
imagine you wouldn't die at all if it
were up to you you would choose not to
die but it isn't so you have to die so
there's no taking charge of that so so
you know trying to take charge or do it
your own way so you kill yourself before
you die that's like if you heard that a
guy's coming to your house to burn it to
the ground and so you head him off at
the pass by burning it to the ground
yourself and then when he shows up you
say you see what I did you see I won no
in that case to take charge of the
we'll be to stand outside your house
with a shotgun and when the guy comes
you make him leave
but you can't do that with death when
death comes and it will for all of us
all you can do is accept it you can you
can choose to accept it earlier than God
intends and by your own hand but that is
no kind of victory but I think the
biggest problem here with that way of
thinking is that our lives are our
deaths as well these are not things that
we can own people want to people want to
own death you know they want to grab a
hold of it that's that's what that's
what euthanasia is all about what the
culture of death is a lot as much of it
that's what it's about it's about
grabbing hold of death and trying to
make it into something controllable so
ironically it's the people who fear
death the most who are the ones who are
in favor of euthanasia and all that
because it's the nature of the it's the
suddenness of death it's the unwieldy
uncontrollable nature of death that they
fear and they think they can make it a
less fearful thing by grabbing hold of
it and quote doing it on their terms but
death is not something you could grab
hold of nor should you try it's not
something you can own for the same
reason that we can't own our lives as
much as we talk about bodily autonomy
there's no autonomy and this is what's
so beautiful and terrifying and
mysterious and wonderful and awful about
about life is that it's outside of our
control
I didn't decide to come into existence
to come into being I didn't decide who I
was gonna be I didn't decide what my
identity was gonna be I didn't decide
who my parents were who what my family
was was it you know I didn't die I
didn't decide what country I would be
born in I don't decide consciously to
have my heart pump and my my lungs
breathe and my blood flow all that stuff
happens on its own I
decide anything about the culture the
civilization the country that I was born
into this was all selected for me by
something else or someone else and if
you're an atheist then you believe that
it was all decided by a series of
accidents and circumstances and you
could have just as well been born a
cockroach or a tree or or a kangaroo and
really there's very little difference
between all those different things
because life is happenstance and you are
happenstance you are effectively meaning
yes meaningless but even then even in
from the atheistic point of view by this
logic euthanasia makes no sense it's a
crime against nature really in an
atheist world all you have is this
existence that's it and then it's over
and then you just you just you just kind
of dissolve into the void and there's
nothing left of you so the only
imperative in a world like that is just
to live and to extend your existence for
as long as possible that's the only
point if we live in an atheistic world
there is no point to life other than
simply to live it for as long as
possible and then you don't exist so in
an atheistic world euthanasia is a sick
joke it's a crime against the Darwinian
order of things really and then from a
religious perspective from a
monotheistic perspective all of this my
life my circumstance my identity it was
decided by a divine force by by God
before the beginning of time and so I
this is the beautiful thing that I was
an idea in the mind of God and he spoke
me into existence from the midst of
eternity he plucked me out of eternity
and he placed me into time which is a
beautiful thing and I belong
to him I am his creation I own nothing
least of all my own life every day that
I wake up every step I take every pulse
of my heart all of this is sustained by
God all of it and he has a plan he has a
reason every morning when I wake up it's
okay well that's another I guess I get
another day or at least another few
moments and there's a reason for that
you might not understand the reason I
might not understand the reason
completely but there's a reason if God
your God decides when your time is up
when your story's finished there's gonna
come a point when your story really is
finished when it's been told when you've
done everything you could do or that God
wanted you to do and for better or worse
that's the end of it last page right
that time will come and we don't know
when and some people end up with much
bigger books than others
but that's for God to decide and to
reject the life that he's given me to
reject even one day of it to reject one
hour one minute is a terrible thing it's
the worst thing in the world because
I've not only rejected my life but I've
rejected the entire world the world that
he has made for me I have rejected it
I've said I don't want it anymore God
and in doing that I've also rejected God
so take your pick either you believe in
God or you don't you're an atheist or
you're not maybe you're somewhere
in-between but no matter where you fall
on the spectrum euthanasia is a horrific
horrible terrible thing and we should
all be against it and I haven't even
talked about to say this
other video but the other big problem
with euthanasia aside from not that I'd
really need to list any more problems
with it it's an aside from what I've
already said but we have the continued
perversion and degradation of the
medical profession you know doctors are
supposed it's the Hippocratic oath
doctors do no harm they're always
supposed to heal and treat and cure
that's the job of a doctor and because
of abortion and now with euthanasia
we have also made doctors into merchants
of death which is the exact opposite of
what they're supposed to be what they're
supposed to be we need doctors to
cherish life and it becomes a very you
know once euthanasia becomes commonplace
as it is not quite here yet but in some
parts of the world once it becomes
commonplace it's a it's quite a conflict
of interest for a doctor or a conflict
of something it's certainly an internal
conflict because in one room you know he
goes to see a patient and the patient is
terminally ill patient wants to live so
the doctor is fighting for his life the
next room over st. you know a guy has
the same terminal illness and in this
case he wants to die the doctor says
okay here's some poison no we want
doctors to be to be wired to fight
always for life once they start dealing
out death as well it's it's the end of
the medical profession and I think
that's pretty serious downside as well
alright that's it for me hope you guys
have a great weekend I'll talk to you on
Monday